Anna wants to celebrate her birthday by
eating pizza with her friends for 40 to
50 total they can buy P boxes of pizza
each box of pizza costs $8.50 select the
equation that matches this situation so
before I even look at these let's see if
I can make sense of the sentence here so
for 40 to 50 total and I'll just write
42.5 especially because in all these
choices they didn't write 40 to 50 they
just wrote 42 point 5 which is which is
equivalent so 40 to 50 that's the total
amount the total the amount the total
amount they spent on pizza and if I want
to figure out how many pieces how many
boxes of pizza they could buy I could
divide the total amount they spend I
could divide that by the price per box
and then that would give me the number
of boxes so this is the total total
dollars this right over here is the
dollar per box and then this would give
me the number of boxes number of boxes
now other ways that I could think about
it I could say well what's the total
that they spend so 40 to 50 but what's
another way of thinking about the total
they spend well you could have the
amount they spend per box times the
number of boxes so this is a total they
spend and this is another way of
thinking about the total they spend so
these two things must be equal so let's
see if I can see anything here that
looks like this well actually this first
choice this is exactly is exactly what I
wrote over here let's see this choice
right over here P is equal to 8.5 times
forty two point five well we've already
been able to write an equation that has
explicitly that has just a p on one side
and so when you solve for just a p on
one side you get this thing over here
not this thing so we could rule that out
and over here we it looks kind of like
this except the p is on the wrong side
this has 8.5 P is equal to 40 2.5 not
forty two point five P is equal to eight
point five and if we try to get the P on
the other side here you could divide
both sides by P but then you would get P
divided by P is one you would get 42
point five
is equal to 8.5 over P which is not true
we have 8.5 times P is equal to 42 point
5 so this is this is not going to be the
case and one thing to realize no matter
what you come up with if you came up
with this first or if you came up with
this first you can go between these two
with some algebraic with some algebraic
manipulations so for example to go from
this blue one to what I wrote in red up
here you just divide both sides by 8.5
so you divide by 8.5 on the left you
divide 8.5 on the right obviously to
keep the equal sign you have to do the
same thing to the left right but now you
would have forty two point five over
eight point five is equal to is equal to
P which is exactly what we have over
there let's do one more of these good
practice mr. Herman's class is selling
candy for a school fundraiser the class
has a goal of raising five hundred
dollars by selling C boxes of candy for
every box they sell they make $2.75
write an equation that the students
could solve to figure out how many boxes
of candy they need to sell how many
boxes of candy they need to sell well
there's a couple of ways you could think
about it they have a goal of raising
five hundred dollars and so they want to
get a total of five hundred dollars and
if each box is 275 divide the total by
the amount they get each per box and
then this is going to be equal to the
number of boxes that they need to sell
so this this we've done this this is an
equation that the students could solve
to figure out how many boxes of candy
they need to sell another way you could
think about it it's 275 to 275 per box
times C boxes this is the total amount
of money they will raise whoops this is
the amount so this is the amount that
they will raise and their goal is that
the goal is to raise five hundred
dollars so this they want this to be
equal to five hundred dollars so this
also could be an equation that the
students could solve to figure out how
many boxes of candy they need to sell